[Music]
in spite candy news tight submitted by a
pineapple daddy three daycare workers
have been charged with giving kids
melatonin laced gummy bears that's died
I need some of those that's good keeping
them make them go to that time yeah why
is that bad you would have no problem
with someone drugging Tyco with that
none whatsoever the next video well I'm
glad they chose melatonin because that's
naturally occurring in your body yeah at
least they're caring is it naturally I
don't know melatonin [ __ ] me up though I
can't I can't take any of that [ __ ] I
said wake up dreaming still I heard if
you take too much of great spaces in
your brain is it true I don't know I
take a 5 milligram pill I don't know
much about that stuff depending basis in
your brain yeah I've heard that
that's ecstasy cuz it makes your head
like Swiss cheese I thought I was
something about your spinal fluid that's
acid oh I know I've tried melatonin and
it doesn't really make me sleep any
better so I don't take it I sleep good
but I still wake up tired
oh yeah melatonin helps me out just to
get to that point so usually let's say
my sleeping like I lay in bed everything
off it takes about 3-4 hours for me to
knock out damn melatonin it gives it in
- it's about an hour - yes if my kids be
little [ __ ]
[Music]
then you have to add a little bit more
black woman in it yes so true I wonder
if I will have my kids they like on a
real no I see it but I'm not quite sure
yet cuz I guess the thing about this is
like if your kids being rambunctious and
they the person drugs and because of
that but there is a specialist and
they're getting they're a professional
now because they're getting paid for
this specific job and if they can't do
it but what if they want to just [ __ ]
off on the farm a little bit you know
what the rule of thumb is don't let your
kid be taking care about people you
don't know well not everyone has that
luxury I rather be dirt poor homeless
24/7 with my kids begging for food
[ __ ] living in a cemetery I rather do
that [ __ ] kid what do you live
I'll break into one of those nice
luxurious cemetery ones where you can go
inside and then I can make a little
house in there how do you get air in
there it's not very fun alone no you
know though big it's like what do you
call it Julian
yeah like they're like the size of these
two tables they're made out of concrete
and then there's a door man yeah I guess
that's what it's called - if it's not
call mausoleum would you give it up
there's a door it's like a human
doghouse basically
and he keeps described to get born the
exact place you're talking about
I keep hearing Museum there's a fruit
that's yellow and long and is slightly
curved a banana
I will live there rather than letting
your kid go to a place where they get
your hell yeah good that was your point
well I don't want nobody watching my
kids [ __ ] that that's the point I'm
retiring for the forever what happened
why you will be so terrible like
overbearing to them that's my goal I had
an ex with parents who wanted to know
every little thing that was going on in
her life and then therefore in my life
and it was the most annoying [ __ ] and
they would like want to know that they
would make everything into drama because
they're so [ __ ] bored oh no I just
want people to play with okay there's
kids we're gonna do so many fun [ __ ]
wake up build a sandcastle
after that we'll kick it down and then
build it again and then after that we'll
play some volleyball and after that
we're gonna do karate moves and after
it's gonna be a day full of fun every
day whoo what are your kids like that I
used to pretty [ __ ] tired that was
you knocking for the sandcastles dad
every day with the damn sandcastles dad
why can't I learn how to read
you know Dean we're really sad yeah
I just want to play partners hurry up
and get older so we can do [ __ ]
sparring and [ __ ] what's a bar
telepsychic I everyday cuz wants to
wrestle other ones stuff yeah you said
yeah we're bigger so I could do more fun
stuff if you play if it's cheap like
basketball swimming with Matt so I can't
wait for watch my kid watch all my
favourite movies for the first time [ __ ]
oh I'll be so awesome and then the
crushing moment when you realize it's
not that significant to them compared to
how it was for you with music all the
time when I'm showing Isaac like my
favorite songs he's like hey you got
ugly tastes that's what he's thinking we
always do that though to people like I
love doing that I did that to make you
feel like the first year we're dating
it's like oh this movie it's like the
best movie it'll blow your mind all this
[ __ ] and then you're like once you're
watching like I showed Muriel the movie
that was one of my favorite films as she
almost left me so remember I saw the
devil yeah oh how cuz it's scary
yeah but she told you sugar in a [ __ ]
up place right cuz why that's a
spiritual place though you know I'm
saying she kept telling him I don't want
to watch it I'm terrified of scary
movies and all I said to her was like if
you don't love this movie I hate you
that's all I said yeah that's a bad she
didn't love it but I didn't really I
didn't realize I was sleeping how scary
was room yeah he fell asleep waking up
to hearing Muriel screams OH
somebody back Oh just watching a movie I
mean there's a very like intense scene
in the beginning and like she just had
to wait for the retribution so the
reason why that happen is a purpose in
it well you can't just describe it to
sit you can't describe your girlfriend a
Steve like this you have to like give
him the backstory of how well she's a
very sweet girl loves dis
Oh Disney she likes all animated [ __ ]
like every time you go to Disneyland
like Tinkerbell comes down at at from
the nose hello Mary oh that's how she is
her idea of violence is probably Michael
Jackson's be dat music video
exactly so now it makes [ __ ] the best
man yeah so I kind of [ __ ] up on that
one no I'll do that yeah I do it
especially for food when it comes to
chests like this is [ __ ] bomb
I don't like seafood no but this one's
gonna be [ __ ] amazing and I'm just
waiting
we all think our opinions are the best
ones and then we find out crushingly
that they're not that's why I would
Muriel to like when she just eats food I
don't ask her opinion about it cuz gonna
hurt your feelings a little bit yep like
I'll take was she like see I don't know
how to do I know her taste that's why
she likes a healthy food that tastes
like [ __ ] it's so like if I if I take
her to places that if I take it a place
like street tacos or whatever right it's
like unhealthy and it's bombed to me or
spawned below half the population yet of
course she just goes it's good and I'm
like yeah I [ __ ] hate you
4,000 people that agree with me you
don't like this place yeah and then and
then the girl is left being like all
right well you got 4,000 [ __ ]
supporters get the [ __ ] off my back
that's like I said Nikki fast in the
Furious 7 or some [ __ ] oh no oh my this
is literally the greatest movie and I'm
like by the way everyone agrees because
400 million people Gina's movie are you
ready for the ride of your life and then
she's like this [ __ ] is gay is like the
most hilarious film to me because people
watch it because of how ridiculous it is
yeah you clearly see that you're not
supposed to laugh it but everybody die
they take it so seriously while it's so
[ __ ] silly jokes always the only
person cut like our row is the only
group laughing they're really trying to
get into it
this is so bad as it were just [ __ ]
bad mate I can't wait to watch the next
one with you guys cuz I do that too I'm
the only guy then these all got married
in a tank top
right this is a good moment
and and I know he said brother and
family like literally 72 times during
you know how they're promoting the next
one right this is something about family
like yeah
like big family / there is one of my
favorite scenes in fast and furious is
when Vin Diesel flies to the front of a
[ __ ] car right goes over through a
tank after tank falls off a bridge he
lands into another car windshield right
he gets up and there's still the lines
from his fresh shirt like nothing
happened to him no blood no nothing and
he literally put this fresh like shirt
on him yep and it was unscathed you've
been doing it for seven years one of my
favorite scenes is when Paul Walker and
his wife and I think Vin Diesel were
running through like the underground
sewer and they get out and they're like
should we call the left or right cuz
they're being chased and his wife goes I
have something to tell you or how many
[ __ ] circling shots are there and
that [ __ ] not enough for me man give
me ten more it's literally the same with
like Vin Diesel and Letty are talking to
each other and it just started spinning
constantly as I'm going through the
whole conversation
I love it they were fused and a director
on set public yeah no dude he's drinking
monster energy drink keep it [ __ ] go
[Laughter]
I feel like the directors of all the
fast franchises they do it as they're
like trolls I feel like they just put
everything on steroids for fun because
they're all legit directors yeah they
are all tomorrow yeah cuz they just have
to do whatever is great for the
franchise
that's just all what they got to do if
you're doing mama you got to do the
bottom of it you can't like be better
than the Bond movie while you do it
you have to like playing in the what it
is I know I can't wait you gonna do that
[ __ ] would be 70 and he's still gonna
look better than me with his shirt off
what the [ __ ] is he still at the same
age I have no idea is that even possible
I don't know look it and then sometimes
in some scenes I'm like looks a little
droopy here thank God and then the next
thing I'm like no he looks perfect again
what happened
well my mr. Smee on his tooth is right
in the middle like it doesn't it's in
the center I mean yeah in the center God
and you don't know where all the
Scientology [ __ ] I still love him Tom
Cruise is the mother plate is sold
perfectly as a star yeah he doesn't talk
about politics too much and none of that
[ __ ] like he just he just does his
[ __ ] thing he doesn't talk much
Church and like he's lovable he's gay
right I just love that guy but that was
the one time he slept he never did it
again that was just that one interview
and that was it he said I showed too
much of my personality
it was a touch of Tom that we never got
and then we never got it again because
he was like oh I see he was married to
who kitty who is now with Jamie Foxx he
tore through the finest [ __ ] in
Hollywood
yes Nicole Kidman yeah Oh Nicole bride
Nicole kid prime yeah yeah Rhys Eyes
Wide Shut Nicole Kidman I thank you yes
Batman Forever Nicole Kidman forever
come on forget it
take my keys throw my keys away Eyes
Wide Shut Nicole Kidman was amazing and
now I'll be Cruz okay he toured through
it he told that [ __ ] it that's what he
did I'm talking we're not gonna open our
gruesome back in like current Dana we're
talking like vulvar Penelope Cruz I'm
saying Pedro almodóvar our movie
Penelope Cruz we all know what I'm
talking about
everyone knows Penelope Cruz is so dope
I don't know what the [ __ ] she ever says
in a film nobody cares I just heard that
I [ __ ] love you
[Music]
Oh